Você já pensou em um dia reduzir ou até
sair da metiformina, famoso clifage?
Calma, não é para jogar remédio fora.
Mas em 2025, alguns estudos começaram a
incomodar muita gente que lucra com a
diabetes. Eles mostram que um composto
natural extraído de plantas consegue
resultados muito parecidos, em alguns
pontos até superiores ao medicamento
mais prescrito do mundo para diabetes
tipo 2. Eu estou falando da berberina, o
alcaloide presente em várias plantas
como bérberes e felodendro. E o objetivo
desse vídeo não é fantasia nem promessa
milagrosa, é comparar com base em
ciência o que que a mente formina faz, o
que que a berberina faz, onde cada uma
ganha e como esse conhecimento pode ser
usado de forma estratégica,
principalmente se você quer ter mais
autonomia sobre sua saúde metabólica. Em
poucos minutos eu vou te mostrar números
de ensaios clínicos recentes, explicar
de forma simples o mecanismo de ação
dessas duas substâncias, comentar doses,
efeitos colaterais, no final apresentar
um protocolo prático que eu uso na minha
visão funcional. E se você ficar até o
fim, vai entender porque a indústria não
tem nenhum interesse em que você
compreenda bem essa história. Contexto,
a queridinha da medicina e a planta
esquecida.
Vamos começar pelo óbvio. A metiformina
é h décadas o padrão ouro pro tratamento
do diabetes tipo 2. É barata, tem boa
eficácia, reduz o risco de progressão do
pré-diabetes paraa diabetes e faz parte
dos consensos mudo aa eu não sou contra,
eu sou muito a favor da metformina,
inclusive ela é um fitoterápico, ela tem
o seu lugar especialmente em
determinados perfis de pacientes. Mas
existe um detalhe que pouca gente
discute. A metiformina foi patenteada,
gerou e ainda gera muito dinheiro. Já a
berberina é uma molécula natural usada
há muito tempo na medicina tradicional
chinesa e indiana. Por ser naturalmente
encontrada em plantas, não pode ser
patenteada da mesma forma que a
metifomina foi. E sem patente forte, não
existe incentivo econômico para
financiar grandes ensaios clínicos
caríssimos. Resultado, por muitos anos a
beberina ficou relegada a algo entre
fitoterápico exótico e curiosidade de
estudo pequeno. Só que os dados foram se
acumulando, acumulando, especialmente
nos últimos 15 a 20 anos e isso começou
a mudar o jogo. Hoje temos ensaios
clínicos comparando diretamente bberina
e metiformina em pré-diabéticos e
diabéticos e revisões sistemáticas,
mostrando resultados muito consistentes.
E vamos a acessão. ciência simplificada,
o botão metabólico MPK. Então, para
entender essa história, imagine que
dentro de cada célula sua existe uma
espécie de gerente de energia. Esse
gerente é uma enzima chamada MPK. Ela
funciona como um sensor de bateria
fraca. Quando a MPK é ativada, o recado
é: estamos com energia baixa, vamos usar
combustível de forma mais eficiente. E o
que que isso significa na prática? O
corpo aumenta a captação de glicose
pelas células, reduz a produção de
glicose pelo fígado, estimula o uso de
gordura estocada como fonte de energia.
Em outras palavras, você melhora a
sensibilidade insulina e diminui a
glicose circulante. Tanto a metiformina
quanto a beberina, eles ativam essa via
MPK. É por isso que alguns chamam a
beberina de metiformina natural. A
metiformina faz isso principalmente ao
inibir o complexo um da cadeia
respiratória mitocondrial. gerando um
leve estresse energético que dispara a
MPK. Então, a beberina também interfere
na mitocôndria, mas ela não se limita a
isso. Estudos recentes mostram que além
da MPK, a beberina modula a Cirtium, que
é a proteína ligada à longevidade e ao
metabolismo mitocondrial, é uma das
cirtuínas. Ela também atua sobre o PGC1
alfa, que regula a biogênese
mitocondrial, ajudando a criar
mitocôndrias mais eficientes. Interfere
com PCS
K9, que é a proteína que influencia os
receptores de LDL no fígado, o que ajuda
a reduzir essa forma de colesterol,
inibe o inflamaçoma NLRP3
e isso vai reduzir marcadores
inflamatórios como TNF alfa e
interleucinas pró-inflamatórias. Além
disso, ela ativa o NRF2, que aumenta a
produção de enzimas antioxidantes, como
gluta hiperóxidesmutá, e também modula
profundamente a microbiota intestinal,
favorecendo bactérias produtoras de
butirato e outras substâncias
antiflamatórias. Enquanto a metiformina
foca sobretudo em glicose, a beberina
tem um espectro mais amplo, atingindo
glicemia, lipídios, inflamação,
estresse oxidativo e microbiota.
Colocando no ring metiformina versus a
berberina. Então vamos comparar de forma
objetiva com alguns dados. Em termos de
controle glicêmico, um ensaio clínico
indiano de 2025 avaliou 90 pacientes
pré-diabéticos. Eles foram divididos em
dois grupos. Um recebeu berberina 500 mg
duas vezes ao dia. O outro metiformina
500 mg duas vezes ao dia por 12 semanas.
Então no grupo da berberina, a glicemia
de jejum caiu em torno de 12 mg por dil.
no grupo da metiformina, cerca de 10.
Então, a glicemia pósperandial também
caiu um pouco mais com a berberina.
Então, a hemoglobina glicada reduziu
aproximadamente 0,31 pontos com a
berberina e 0,28 pontos com aformina.
Então, em termos de consultório, é
praticamente um empate com leve vantagem
pra berberina. Esse não é um estudo
isolado. Tem um estudo clássico chinês
de 2008 em diabéticos tipo 2 recém
diagnosticados. já tinha mostrado algo
parecido. Berberina 500 mg três vezes ao
dia por 3 meses reduziu a hemoglobina
glicada de cerca de 9,5 para 7,5%.
Resultado muito similar ao grupo
metiformina. A diferença que a berberina
nesse estudo reduziu significativamente
triglicerídeos e melhorou o perfil
lipídico, enquanto a metiformina ficou
praticamente neutra nesse ponto. Vamos
falar então de perfil lipídico e cine
metabólico. Aqui a berina costuma se
destacar através do efeito sobre a MPK,
PGC1 alfa e PCSK9.
Então ela reduz triglicerídeos, reduz o
LDL colesterol, pode aumentar
discretamente o HDL e melhora a
qualidade das partículas de LDL, que é
muito mais importante que qualquer outra
coisa. Então isso é especialmente
importante em pacientes com cí
metabólica, nos quais o problema não é
apenas glicose, mas todo um contexto de
resistência insulina, gordura visceral e
deslipidemia heterogênea. Vamos falar
então de intestino, inflamação e
complicações.
Diabetes tipo 2 não é sócar alto, é
inflamação crônica de baixo grau,
disfunção endotelial, que é aquela parte
interna da parede das artérias, para de
funcionar direito. também estresse
oxidativo, disbiose intestinal e lesão
progressiva de rins, nervos e retina.
Então, a metiformina tem efeitos
benéficos, mas é relativamente limitada
nessa parte inflamatória. A beberina,
por sua vez, ela reduz o inflamaçoma
NLRP3,
UTNF alfa e teleucinas inflamatórias.
aumenta a atividade NRF2,
melhorando a resposta antioxidantes e
modula a microbiota intestinal,
favorecendo bactérias que produzem
ácidos grassos de cadeia curta, que é o
caso do butirato. Além disso, ela
protege o endotélio arterial, reduz
expressão de moléculas de adesão ligadas
à formação de placa. Então, em modelos
experimentais, protege contra a
nefropatia, que é doença dos ins,
retinopatia, doença da retina e
neuropatia diabética, indo além do
simples controle da glicose. Do ponto de
vista funcional, a beberina conversa com
a raiz do problema metabólico de forma
mais ampla. Vamos falar então de efeitos
colaterais e segurança. A metiformina é
bem conhecida pelos efeitos
gastrointestinais. Ela pode dar
diarreia, náusea, desconforto abdominal.
Em uso prolongado pode levar deficiência
de vitamina B12 em uma parcela dos
pacientes e em situações específicas
existe o risco raro de acidose láctica.
A berberena também pode causar
desconforto gastrointestinal em parte
das pessoas, especialmente no início,
levando gases, cólicas leves, mudança de
ritmo intestinal. Normalmente isso é
transitório nas primeiras semanas e
melhora com ajuste de doses. Em ensaios
clínicos comparativos, a taxa de efeitos
gastrointestinais costuma ser um pouco
menor com berberina do que com
metiformina. Um ponto importante, a
beberina interage com sistemas
enzimáticos do fígado, como CIP 3A4, CIP
2D6, podendo alterar o metabolismo de
outras medicações. Portanto, ela exige
cuidado especial em quem usa múltiplos
fármacos de uso contínuo, especialmente
imunosupressores e alguns
cardiovasculares. Vamos ao protocolo
prático. Como usar berberina de uma
maneira inteligente. O que que a
literatura clínica mostra de forma mais
consistente? é o uso de doses entre 1000
e 100 mg por dia divididos em duas ou
três tomadas. Uma estratégia
conservadora que equilibra eficácia e
tolerabilidade é iniciar com 500 mg
antes do jantar por alguns dias,
avaliando a tolerância gastrointestinal.
Depois subir para 500 mg antes do almoço
e 500 mg antes do jantar. Em casos
selecionados, chegar a 500 mg três vezes
ao dia antes das principais refeições. E
a razão de tomar antes da refeição é
dupla. Aproveitar o efeito sobre enzimas
intestinais que quebram carboidratos e
modular o pico glicêmico pósprandial.
Então, existe um detalhe técnico. A
bemina tem biodisponibilidade oral
baixa. Grande parte da ação dela
acontece justamente no intestino e no
fígado via circulação portal, o que é
suficiente para efeito metabólico.
Porém, hoje já existem formulações
avançadas como micelas, fitossomas ou de
hidrobeberina que aumentam a absorção e
permitem doses menores com efeito
semelhante. Em colidratos de berberina
comum, a prioridade passa a ser escolher
um produto com laudo de terceiros e
pureza próxima de 98% e usar dentro de
um contexto de dieta adequada, estilo de
vida ativo e sono organizado. Do ponto
de vista de segurança, alguns grupos não
são bons candidatos para uso de
beberina. é o caso das gestantes, dos
lactantes, das crianças, indivíduos com
insuficiência hepática, né, do fígado ou
renal grave e pessoas em uso de céros e
usos supressores, entre outros cenários
especiais. E quando que nós devemos
considerar a combinação com metiformina?
Uma uma pergunta comum que eu recebo é
se faz sentido usar bemina junto com
etifomina e não no lugar de do ponto de
vista mecanístico faz porque embora
ambas ativem mpk elas têm alvos
adicionais diferentes. Há estudos em que
a beberina foi adicionada em pacientes
que já usavam mitifomina e não tinham
bom controle, mostrando melhora
adicional em glicemia e marcadora de
estresse oxidativo. Em resumo, a
beberina pode ser usada isoladamente em
pré-diabetes, simple metabólica, casos
mais leves, dentro de um pacote de
mudança e estilo de vida, como adjuvante
a drogas cometiformina em casos mais
complexos, sempre com atenção às
interações e parâmetros laboratoriais.
Vamos concluir aqui o que que realmente
importa para você. Berberina e
metiformina não são inimigas, são
ferramentas. A metiformina continua
sendo muito importante tendo seu papel,
especialmente em um modelo mais
tradicional de conduta. A beberina surge
como alternativa ao complemento, com
potencial de atuar não só na glicose,
mas também em lipídios, intestino,
inflamação e proteção tecidual. O ponto
central é que deixar tudo na mão apenas
de uma abordagem medicamentosa
convencional, sem olhar para nutrição,
sono, trem de força, massa muscular,
microbiota e inflamação crônica, é uma
estratégia fraca. Em contrapartida,
entender o composto como a bberina é um
passo em direção a recuperar o controle
da própria biologia em vez de apenas
reagir a números de laboratório. Agora,
um aviso direto, se você se contenta com
o superficial, esse é o momento de sair
do vídeo. O que eu posso falar aqui é
limitado pelo algoritmo, por regras de
plataforma e por modelo de medicina que
muitas vezes prefere que você continue
independente de soluções parciais. Na
comunidade fechada o cenário é outro. Lá
eu compartilho protocolos completos que
eu utilizo na prática clínica, incluindo
combinações de beberina com outros
nutrientes e fármacos, casos de reversão
e controle avançado de cinometabólica e
diabetes que dificilmente caberiam em
vídeo público. Orientações sobre
qualidade suplementos, fornecedores
sérios e interpretação refinada de
exames. É na prática ter acesso direto
ao meu raciocínio clínico sem o filtro
das redes abertas. Toda semana temos
encontros ao vivo, materiais em PDF com
dezenas de protocolos e um grupo fechado
para discutir dúvidas e resultados. Se
você quer visão profissional de verdade,
sem diluição para massa, clique em seja
membro. E não é para curiosa, é para
quem está realmente disposto a mudar o
seu próprio rumo metabólico. E existe o
nível dois, esse é para poucos. A cada
duas semanas, fazemos imersões de cerca
de 2 horas, desse artigos científicos,
linha por linha, discutindo
controvérsias, revendo evidência e quase
nunca aparecem congressos patrocinados.
Os membros de nível dois têm um nome
citado nos vídeos como forma de
reconhecimento público. É um selo de
pertencimento a uma minoria que decidiu
investir em conhecimento profundo, não
em atalhos fáceis. Enquanto a maioria
continua apenas consumindo informação
passivamente, você pode se tornar parte
de um núcleo que está ajudando a
reescrever a forma como encaramos
metabolismo, enfelhecimento e prevenção.
A pergunta que fica é simples, você quer
continuar apenas assistindo ou quer
participar ativamente dessa mudança?
Agradecimentos especiais a nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada do YouTube. Nível
dois, Dr. Ana Paulo Rodrigues, José
Fortunato Burtinho, Fernando Machado,
Sou Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana
Moraril, Estela Mares, Eloterapias
Integrativas, Luís Anselmo Neves Antes
da Doença. Eu agradeço de coração pelo
apoio prestado.